gibt es irgendetwas was uns die zeit
überbrücken kann bis wir beim thema
impfstoff sind worauf sie im moment
besonders schauen ja es geht natürlich
darum jetzt in der phase bis ein
impfstoff zur verfügung steht
arzneimittel wirksame arzneimittel zur
verfügung zu stellen
gegen das kogit 19 virus und hier haben
auch viele unternehmen wissenschaftliche
institutionen ihr wissen gepolt wir
haben eine riesige datenbanken
analysiert welche arzneimittel wurden
denn schon antiviral eingesetzt und
welche könnten sich denn aufgrund ihres
wirksamkeits prinzips für eine
behandlung gegen das comic 19 virus
eignen
und da hat man verschiedene kandidaten
identifiziert und diese kandidaten
befinden sich bereits schon in
klinischer test und das auch wiederum
gelingt nur wenn zulassungsbehörden wie
das paul-ehrlich-institut das pvdf dr
wenn die hier unterstützend mit
eingreifen da befinden sich auch im
deutschsprachigen raum auch in
deutschland in österreich in der schweiz
sind ungefähr 20 unternehmen derzeit
aktiv und testen solche arzneimittel
einige jetzt bereits schon in der
klinischen prüfung und wir gehen davon
aus dass wir in den nächsten wochen
ergebnisse haben werden zu solchen
bereits auch antiviral wirksamen
arzneimitteln welches wird profil sie
haben gegen das comic 19
zusätzlich werden andere arzneimittel
getestet nämlich sogenannte
immunmodulatoren denn die folge der
kombi 19 infektion ist häufig dass das
immunsystem kollabiert und unter stress
gesetzt wird und daran sterben dann
patienten mit sehr schweren verläufen
auch hier kommen jetzt biotechnologie im
einsatz und auch in deutschland testet
und dann habe ich noch unternehmer
therapeutisch
erstellen testen die sie aus dem plasma
von infizierten patientinnen und
patienten gewinnen und daraus dann
antikörper herstellen sogenannte
therapeutische antikörper
das heißt ist eine vielzahl von
klinischen studien sind ungefähr 300
klinische studien derzeit aktiv weltweit
davon auch viele in deutschland zu
solchen therapeutischen ansätzen und wir
gehen davon aus dass wir arzneimittel
mit einer wirksamkeit gegen eine solche
akute infektion um den verlauf zu
verlangsamen um den verlauf aufzuhalten
zu bremsen
wahrscheinlich mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit vor dem erhalt eines
impfstoffes haben werden oder zumindest
zeitgleich